Tiger Woods arrested for driving under  the influence the 41 year old golf pro  was booked at 7:18 a.m. Monday morning  in Jupiter Florida a spokesperson for  the Jupiter Police told CBS's wpe C an  officer pulled him over around 3:00 a.m.  and the Palm Beach County Sheriff's  Office released tigers booking photo  shortly after the arrest and he was  released just before 11 a.m.  this comes after tiger underwent his  fourth back surgery in April and  revealed on his website last week he has  no plans to retire from his beloved  sport quote I want to say unequivocally  I want to play professional golf again  presently I'm not looking ahead right  now my sole focus is rehab and doing  what the doctors tell me  you